le parti communiste compte fin du mois
de septembre
proposer ce qu'il appelle un pacte
d'engagement commun à partir de cette
consultation la et qui va converger
puisque c'est votre question qui
convergera vraisemblablement avec un
certain nombre de choses que propose
jean luc mélenchon lui même vous fermez
absolument pas la porte à un
rapprochement en vue de la
présidentielle
avec avec jean luc mélenchon nous le
débat aujourd'hui et le débat cac a
lancé pierre laurent depuis plusieurs
mois il est il est un débat qui porte
sur la question deux pour un candidat de
la transformation sociale de gagner
l'élection présidentielle et de gagner
les élections législatives d'avoir une
autre majorité au parlement
c'est ça le débat est donc tout son
effort et consiste à rechercher les
conditions d'une telle candidature
mais cette candidature peut être jean
luc mélenchon si toutes ces forces qui
aujourd'hui se réclame un changement
véritable se réclame vraiment du côté
gauche
et bien si tout l'effort se retrouve
dans la candidature de jean-luc
mélenchon à la peut être jean luc mais
non